foreign
comes from Brad in Idaho why are
teachers consistently in the group of
people that become millionaires I'll
just I'm going to add to this question
he's referring to the Ramsey Solutions
study the largest group of millionaires
ever done over ten thousand and they
were in the top five School teachers of
net worth millionaires that's what he's
referring to he goes on to say is it
because they marry well and have a
spouse with a better income or is there
another reason are there other career
Fields I should look into that
consistently make it into the
millionaire club uh you know I can't
wait for Dave's take on this I'll tell
you one thing that I believe is
absolutely reason that teachers are in
that group is because they are missional
they care deeply about their role we
also found in that same study that 96 96
percent of net worth millionaires love
their work and in the teacher case
they're very dedicated to be instructors
they care deeply about serving kids and
they've chosen work that is Meaningful
to them and thus they've decided that
what they make is enough
and they've made the choices to live on
less than they make and choose a
lifestyle that actually supports their
work not the other way around and I
think it's about deep meaning and
purpose and thus they've been
disciplined and they're very methodical
and I think that's a part that plays too
Dave what would you add to that or do
you does that square with you I think
that's you know when we got the data in
it was interesting to us
um you know the the top five
career fields of the millionaires in the
largest study a Millionaire's ever done
in North America number one was engineer
number two is accountant number three
was teacher number four was business
professional which can mean almost
anything
um and number five was um lawyer
medical doctor didn't even make the top
five the number six and they are
stereotypically worse with money than
music artists I mean it's ridiculous and
so
um not all in other words not all of
them but I'm saying The Stereotype is is
there for a reason so
what we figured out is is that okay why
is it why do these five land there and
and even if we look at further down the
list why do some of these top what what
is what do they have in common and what
it does disprove is that your income
causes you to become a millionaire
because one third of the millionaires
that we studied 33 percent of them never
made over a hundred thousand dollars
so it's not your income
in other words you can't earn your way
out of stupidity
so what did those what does an engineer
an accountant a lawyer business
professional teacher have in common and
I think you hit it on the head when you
said method there they are systems
people they work with a set of
principles
and they don't
um
they don't they don't have free reign to
make up their own rules there when
you're a lawyer and you go before the
judge you have to follow exact
procedures
even exact ways of addressing the court
if it pleases the court your honor you
don't talk to humans out in the at the
gas station that way it's a set of
procedures that you use there's a proper
set of emotions that and you don't have
a choice you don't get to you know well
I'm creative you're you know old man in
the robe you don't get to say that okay
you get to say if it pleases the court
your honor I mean you don't have a
choice in this you don't have a choice
when you're an engineer designing a
bridge there's basically one way
otherwise it falls yep and you know and
accountants don't say uh well this is
creative they call that embezzlement you
know what I mean it's like right and so
accounting is a set of generally
accepted accounting principles Gap and
the the process of doing counting
there's one process and you submit
yourself to proven
principles and methods to be successful
in any of those careers and money works
exactly the same way right you have to
submit yourself to a set of proven
principles you live on less than you
make you're generous you invest you have
a written plan you're in agreement with
your spouse these are set principles
that you don't get to be creative well
in my I don't think it works yeah yeah I
don't agree who gives a crap if you
agree this is the way the bridge is
built yeah this is the way that you do a
lesson plan if you're a teacher this is
the proper methodology for instructing
it is so structured and so they're used
to functioning in in a structured
environment and submitting themselves to
proven structured processes which money
and wealth building are and that's what
the correlation was it took us a little
while to figure it out and let's also
understand that they have to be
intentional to win with their income
because they can't they can't rely on
big increases in income no there are no
bonuses one third of the millionaire has
never made over 100 let me keep that in
mind and here's but Brad let me address
one other thing are there other career
Fields I should look into that
consistently make it to the millionaire
Club no that's right do not pick your
field because you think it's going to
make you rich yeah never do that
but are there processes that you can
submit yourself to yes that will get you
into the millionaire Club absolutely
there are but you don't pick your career
field because what you'll be is a
miserable human being with a big income
if you pick the you know I'm doing this
just for the money money wears off man
you eat enough Lobster it tastes like
soap so true there's just not there's
only so much money so much money will do
and so you you know you don't pick your
no you know it's like you don't pick
your wife based on the net worth of her
father you know that's a bad way of
doing it you know you're going to get
yourself in a mess you know that won't
turn out well no it's going to go poorly
so yeah you you know you pick your
career field based on
purpose and meaning and can you actually
do it you know and so what you've got is
again with teachers or any accountant
they enjoy process accountants enjoy
process and they're talented at it
teachers enjoy instruction they're good
at it that's the mix and then you choose
to make your money work that's what I
love by the way in case so we got a lot
of new people joining all the time we
love this we're here we're growing like
crazy all over the place podcast YouTube
everywhere here's the thing the median
salary right now for teachers in the
United States is about sixty one
thousand dollars you need to understand
net worth millionaires at that level it
can be done and there's this generation
that's watching too many Tick Tock
videos and Instagram videos Dave where
it says you've got to make millions of
dollars a year uh to be wealthy and it's
just simply not true you can't out earn
your stupidity that's a fact I've tried
it
didn't work you just gotta not be stupid
and so you can't make enough money to be
stupid it won't work you'll lose it I
know I did it I did it I did the zeros
on the end I know what it looks like
exactly how it feels I know whatever
every bit of that experience no thank
you I don't want to do it again so
um you know this is what you need to
dial in on do something that you love
and find a way to do it in an unusual
way yes okay yes doesn't necessarily if
you're a teacher it doesn't necessarily
mean you're a classroom teacher there's
a lot of ways to be a teacher and a lot
of things you can do I have a I have a
gift of teaching yeah absolutely Dan so
I'm a teacher if you teach financial
principles in a lot of ways yeah and
I've done it on 60 Minutes and you've
done it in 600 000 600 stations for
years and then you've done it in front
of hundreds of thousands of people and
this gets a very good point you know if
I love instructing I'm not limited to a
public school classroom but that is also
a wonderful place to do it yeah yeah but
it's not the only definition of a
teacher that's correct so um now again
the purposes of that study these were
probably classroom teachers yeah yeah
that's what we talk a lot about sure
yeah but the uh I mean I don't think
someone identifies in a survey of
millionaires that they are a teacher if
they're on the radio that's not probably
not what they're that's probably not
what they're doing right so
um but that's not the plan so that's a
really good question don't pick your
career
based on how much money you can make
only it should be a consideration
but um but but don't pick it based on
that only and go oh I'm going to make a
lot of money and that'll make me happy
while I'm doing stuff every day that I
hate doing no that won't work
but also don't pick a career that says
oh this is going to make me happy and
it's okay if I'm broke that's not
necessarily either no you should make
more money if you're doing something you
love
because you're good at it
because you care about it because you're
creative because you've got energy you
should make more money not less yeah so
that's the way to get at it good
question